this is magnus's power move right we've
seen him do that before you know he when
he arrived two and a half minutes late
for that game in the blitz you know he
literally adjusted all his pieces before
he made his move I mean what kind of
power move is that
wow and uh the game has started after
Magnus kind of gives Hikaru 30 seconds
lead on the clock and it's the exact
same opening tunic that we've seen from
Hikaru several surprised not surprised
he decided this way he's not losing and
wasting energy rethink what to do yeah
let's go for it this is what I decided I
want to put my energy and invest it in
other things in the middle game and game
when you have to shuffle things the way
to to turn things around wow and Magnus
taking a long think it's only move six
this is really surprising kind of
forfeiting a few minutes on the clock
here pretty much and okay he plays
Bishop to F5 for a logical move
developing pieces and what does Hikaru
have in store just Rock Solid almost a
London system set up here for White and
the players will now just slowly develop
the pieces the action will be much later
in the game Magnus will hope that the
clock times balance out before that yeah
and uh Hikaru actually asking Magnus a
question now with this last queen move
he's just saying how are you going to
defend the pawn on B7 and still there
are some questions there because if the
queen does step forward I mean first of
all if I were playing with the white
pieces I would come in with my Bishop to
the B5 square and get ready to jump in
with the Knight on E5
yeah looks very tempting now the
question is whether Bishop B5 can be
played with an idea of Knight E5 and
what Magnus has in mind whether is he
really going to play F6 to stop that
well just to cover the E5 Square hoods
possible Magnus has done crazier stuff
but maybe he just wants to go Bishop D6
after Bishop B5
yeah well let's see yeah we'll find out
the answer to the question okay he
trades now now
is it too crazy to actually take that
Knight with the king the king will be
stranded in the center of the board for
the rest of the game that's true wow he
plays a Hikaru really desperate to win
here and Magnus reacts lightning fast
with F6 no night jumps for you and wow
I'm not sure it was a good sign that hit
his Direction no it was a bit one-track
mind I think he needed to because where
are you going with your king usually
you're not castling alongside in this
systems right right and and you and one
other thing that is quite concerning for
white is actually this light Square
Bishop that black has on the F5 Square
because the king is never going to find
any safety on the queen side with that
piece looming on the board
I mean black can even go very aggressive
G5 G4 kind of stuff
oh
but anymore Knight D4 alarm bells
ringing though E5 let's step forward
[Music]
the hikara really Breaking All the Rules
because you know we're taught first of
all don't move your king into the
opening into the center and then
certainly don't open any lines he is
Fisher random world champion though and
this does look like official random game
with the King out on D2 so will he get
time after the queen trade that's about
to happen to run back with his King to
safety I'm really surprised I must admit
by magnus's last move very strange go
for checkmate when your opponent's king
is in the center that's what we're
taught but I think he's just saying
simply saying look the bishop on G3 lock
ER continue the dancing on the queen
side it's a good G5
H5 yeah
tapping forward with all the pawns he's
going to gain gain space on both sides
on both flanks here as black it's still
a beautiful position here for Magnus but
I'm really shocked he didn't go for
checkmate to try and punish well maybe
he just wants to play for one result do
result sorry
thank you
any things that okay probably Nakamura
so will not feel too comfortable with
this with white because he just sits and
wait what kind of plans Magnus will work
out H4 G5 King G6 Rook d8
oops yeah what's this what's this D5 is
hanging yeah
maybe just playing too slow it feels
like he's not quite in the zone in this
game instead of going for checkmate he's
been forced to allow a bunch of Trades
don't forget that Bishop on H2 yeah one
bad piece that's White's problem long
term right has nine pounds maybe nine
pawns and uh not enough pieces
yeah okay but at least some pressure has
been relieved with this uh last exchange
like this one has to be very instructive
C5 C4 sorry in every game in every game
it seems to be like the formula right
gets developed pieces get C4 in ta-da
yeah and some tactics some tricks here
you have to be really careful it's black
actually this pawns being undermined and
your knight is really loose in the
center of the board yeah now it's
so anyone's game I mean is White's idea
so if black were to double Rooks on the
C line this is simply to go B4 Pro or a
problem for right for black that Rook C8
does not work because C takes D5 Rook C1
X on E6 and captures the niton
on e4 and okay the H2 Bishop is bad but
two Bishop versus The Rook is plus yeah
yeah huge threats how does Magnus deal
with this Pawn 6 Pawn is a winning idea
if he gets time hikaranakamura suddenly
the clocks as well Magnus down to 30
seconds he's gonna regret kind of
forfeiting that 30 seconds he played too
fast made decisions
oh wow action it is all happening fire
on the board lots of calculation to be
done
and right now white can go upon up in
the end game if they just uh if Hikaru
here just takes this black Bishop with a
check and then recaptures on F3 but he's
thinking of something else but it does
if he were to grab that pawn
his Bishop on H2 would be saddled there
until the end of times
and that's something that is
strategically rarely really concerning
very interesting this move with Magnus
play G4
he's not scared of getting his Knight
trapped on the edge of the board I would
be slightly uh kind of worried here if I
were Magnus Carlson this Black Knight
has no Escape squares that's why Hikaru
has stepped forward F4 taking away the
G5 Square from Black's Knight now all
Hikaru needs is to teleport his King
over to G2 wow no way back now for that
piece
Magnus playing with fire
just King F1 Retreat Rogue GA took C7
and White's playing with an extra piece
essentially the white king the white
Bishop they are kind of canceling out
the black Rook at night right now Magnus
is totally stuck totally immobilized
I hate what Magnus has been doing and
there we go Judith White's Rook is
activating
could we see white just be winning in
the next few moves
funny setup having the bishop on H
tonight on H3
don't try it at home that's uh the
problem actually the bishop is coming
into the game
but uh Magnus is wriggling hard you know
mother Rick has come to G4 H4 is
threatened
4 takes H4 yes
takes and then you go H4 you win back
the PC you win back to the white Bishop
at the end but I don't understand why
hikaru's there we go not just activating
his Rook you can hit my Bishop but I'll
just happily Retreat and the black
Knight's still trapped for the rest of
the game Magnus under 20 seconds and his
position is concerning
he has positions more than concerning it
might just be lost here and under 10
seconds as you say Ivanka
what next where's he going with that
black king really mysterious stuff he
can barely move and now Nakamura is just
going Pawn hunting going for Black's
pawns on the queen side and grab them
why not well
how many seconds 15 seconds for Hikaru
and time out just to see whether he can
grab the pawn and that's a good King G4
but now what Knight F2 King H3 he has
his magic ideas this is the definition
of magic Judith look at what he's done
the black king has crept into the
position he's going for the win Magnus
if he can get his King into the F3
Square Hikaru has to pull the brakes and
he has to do it now
he's a piece up Hikaru but uh White's
Bishop is so trapped and the clock is
ticking down and the King has come to F3
wow what a resource by Magnus well the
pawns are disappearing still some
Checkmate threats blacks eporn
threatening to come forward and look at
the clock both players seconds left
indecision there from Magnus F4
he's just not taking a free Pawn that
feels like
okay but he didn't go back in
Magnus has got to draw up his sleeve if
he wants it it feels like he can bring
his King across hikar is just repeating
now bringing his Rook trying to give a
check hey Magnus takes the pawn black
has to be the favorite hatred
well the those two extra pawns F4 F3 and
nothing will stop him F3
keep pushing
no go three three times around still
he's just repeating moves here get any
time on the clock the players do have a
two second increment
but he's stuck how can he break through
here Magnus Carlsen getting F3 and it's
gone
two e two and Rook B1
Judah I think he spotted a direct win
there he's still gonna find it though
Magnus Carson he's got three pawns now
the B Pawn running
Hikaru is about to resign three pauses
too much he relaxed
oh my God what a game what a turnaround
I mean this just goes to show it's all
about holding the nerves when the clock
is ticking down on its final seconds and
here comes F3 oof what's that isn't F
what's that everything at this point
and pawns are rolling me black is about
to win
what a painful loss for Nakamura